So I get that you say, look, guys,
we're going to tackle real problems like healthcare and education that are
thorny and human and difficult,
and might not have the same kind of trajectory as like the, um,
the business or consumer facing tech that we're used to.
And then I get that your investors are like, wait a minute.
I didn't sign on for this stuff necessarily. But, you know, come on,
uh, Jamal, you could like pick all these winners and like easier spaces. Uh,
and then eventually you're like, Hey guys, like,
that's not really what I'm about. Um,
so I'm curious how many other folks have the same mindset you do where
it's like, look, I made a lot of money. I want to handle,
I want to tackle really important problems that aren't as market friendly
or timeframe friendly. Um, as the stuff we customarily invest in.
Um, there's a handful of folks. Um, I think that, um, the, the, the sort of the,
the grandfather of the space,
the person who's really pioneered this path is a guy by the name of Linode
Cosla. Um, yeah, he's, uh, he's an incredible entrepreneur and his firm,
coastal ventures, I think has done, um,
huge amounts to help the world in climate change and sustainability and
agriculture. Um, he's an example. I think that there are other, um,
organizations actually now that are more institutional that focus on innovation.
Lux capital is an example based in New York. So there are some, um,
but by and large, the incentives aren't to do that,
the incentives are that you can get paid a lot of money to just basically,
you know, put money into things that are obvious Mark up.
Those companies raise another fund and rinse and repeat because that pays you a
great yearly compensation. And at that point, you know, it's, you, you,
you kind of have to ask yourself,
why would I even bother trying to solve cancer? You know, like this is crazy.
It's just going to take too long, too much money. I may look stupid,
I may get fired. And so, um, you know,
people's own simplified incentives kick in, um, and innovation stops. Yeah.
It's much easier to try and jam yourself into an Airbnb or a pre IPO or
something. And then like turn around and be like, Hey,
like I'm a genius investor.
I had my annual meeting today. And what was so funny is I remember, um,
this is for my historic venture funds, you know, and look,
I've put 1,000,000,003 or four into the ground. And, you know,
I told these guys, look, guys,
you're going to make somewhere between five and $6 billion. So congratulations.
It's all great. And one of my ex partners texted me and he said, you know,
these are the same guys who just got so agitated when you did a 3d, you know,
rocket printing company,
which is now the second most valuable space business after a space X that's
private, you know, where we did this, uh, satellite business.
That's also a multi-billion dollar business where we did a,
an AI chip company that's helping to, you know,
do a lot of interesting things in science. Um, you were just not rewarded.
And again, I go back to this Peter teal discussion.
If Peter hadn't forced me or hadn't put peer pressure on me to put so much money
and I would have never made those investments. Now,
the way that I think about it is look, you know,
I have a pretty like crazy
track record and just kind of making money, which is kind of okay. Um,
it's nothing that I'm particularly proud of, but I want to use it.
And so the way I think about it is, you know,
we have an organization where if you put money in a ton of money comes out,
we've done it for 10 years and it's like 35% of a year return. So when you put,
you know, five or $10 billion into a system like that,
every year you're spitting out two or three or 4 billion of cash,
but then I can take that Andrew and I can pump it into climate change and I can
pump it into education. And, you know, because it's all of our own capital,
all of my own capital, um,
I don't have to answer to anybody except the employees and the founders and the
market. Right. And so, you know, for example,
there was a really incredible innovation that came out a few weeks ago from
Google called, um, alpha fold. Now, what is that?
They're using machines to guess the structure of proteins,
and you may think, well, what does that have to do with me? Well,
as it turns out,
that is the basic building block to eradicate and solve
an enormous swath of diseases.
And so we have reduced an incredible problem of human health to one of
compute power and to one of distribution.
Now that's where I could easily pour a billion dollars of capital spend the next
10 years and say, guys, let's take, you know, crawl, walk, run, and approach.
And let's just have 20 or 30 really important diseases that we can, you know,
basically put out a business. Um,
and I don't have to answer to anybody except the scientists that work on the
projects and then the market and the people suffering from those diseases.
So say tomorrow faster, or, Hey, it doesn't work or, Hey,
it looks like it's working. Um, and so I find myself for the first time,
very happy actually like, you know,
reasonably content because we have this, you know,
it's kind of like being a country, Andrew, I think in like, you know,
like your Saudi Arabia and one day you wake up and it's like,
there's oil underneath your feet. And all you have to do is just suck it out.
And then when you sell it in the market, you have money. Except in our case,
we have a plan with what to do with the money. You know, we,
we have these areas that we just think need to get fixed for humanity,
just to thrive.
That's incredible that you've gotten that kind of, uh,
visibility into some of the thorniest problems.
And you feel like you can make headway in solving them.
I spent a number of years running a nonprofit that was trying to help young
entrepreneurs in different markets around the country,
primarily in the Midwest and the South, I would interact with billionaires. Um,
and then I would say, Hey, support my nonprofit or support this thing I'm doing.
And, uh, if they were into it, they would make a move.
But even if you are a billionaire, you don't move in increments of like,
you know, 25, 30 million.
Like if they were wanting to be really supportive of my organization,
I might get one or 2 million. Um, and then I would be, you know, frankly,
I'll have to be like, well, that's freaking awesome because, you know,
$2 million is like nothing to sneeze at. Um, but,
but there was a sense I had that on among these billionaires.
I knew like they were looking at trying to solve particular problems and they
didn't think they had the resources and you're like, wow, I'm like a,
with a billionaire. And like, they don't think they have it. Um, so I,
I'm curious what your mindset has been when you look at some of like the biggest
problems humanity is facing, uh,
and the scope of the problem relative to the resources that are being applied to
solve that problem.
I, I really haven't met a problem that is really one of capital.
Um, and I think that I have more than enough resources to solve all the problems
that we're trying to solve, except one critical one, which is human capital.
And I think that's the, that's the most important thing to take away,
which is that it's not that, for example, like,
let's just say that you and I said, Hey,
let's go and get every single home in America to be carbon neutral.
Okay. That's a great goal. Right? How would we do it? Well, I can tell you,
I can tell you what the answer is.
And the answer is actually not too complicated, which is every house has a roof.
Every roof can support residential solar.
All of that solar energy can get basically stored onsite in an
extremely safe and predictable battery.
And then you can give the homeowner or the apartment dweller,
an app that allows you to note exactly how much energy those solar cells on the
roof has, um, has generated.
And then you can use it to power the home or the apartment, and whatever's less,
you could put back into the grid. So how do you solve it?
As it turns out it's not one of capital because you can get hundreds of billions
of dollars of project finance to do that because people spend hundreds of
billions of dollars buying the bonds of utilities every single day in the
marketplace.
The really complicated part is can you get 15 or 20 engineers to build the right
app that allows you to basically understand how energy is managed and
re-circulated, can you get the right, you know,
battery scientists and chemists to build the right battery storage technology?
Can you string those batteries together across a neighborhood?
So what I found and I could be totally wrong,
but what I found is that most of these solutions are ones of human
capital and that it doesn't take tens or hundreds of billions of dollars.
People find ways of spending that much money,
but that's just a lot of poor planning. Now, if eventually Andrew,
you and I were to find a solution.
What I would say is it probably would cost 50 million to figure out then you,
and I would say, let's go to a small town like Palo Alto or, you know,
someplace and say, let's deploy that there and figure it out.
And then let's go to a city like Austin or Miami and say, Hey guys,
here's what we found. Let's go roll it out through all of Miami.
And then we would go nationwide. And along the way,
the capital markets are actually very liquid and would give you all that money.
Non-dilutive only.
So it's not that I intend to never work with the capital markets.
I just think that in that early phase,
the single hardest thing to find is actually the people. Um,
and at the end of the day,
these solutions can be found for hundreds of millions of dollars.
This is why I always sort of get trapped in, you know, people,
people have approached me constantly and it's like, Hey,
what's your philanthropic strategy, your charitable strategy. And I,
and I say to be honest with you,
I think that all of these problems that I'm looking at will be solved with
technology oriented solutions. The ones that I am the most, um,
sympathetic to climate change, um, sustainability, agriculture,
um, health education. Um, and so, you know,
eventually we'll, I, you know, find a way to give all the money away. Sure.
But right now, you know,
I think it's important to recycle it till it back into for-profit businesses,
because this is how I solve the human capital problem.
The single biggest thing that America has right now going against it is that we
have four or five companies, Facebook, Apple, Amazon, Microsoft, Google,
that sucks up the enormity and the overwhelming majority of all
talented technical human capital.
Because if you are a smart young kid, you know,
a guy or a girl graduating from a college and you know how to code, or,
you know, how, you know how to do something unique,
how do you turn around to your family and say,
I'm going to go on to work at this startup for 80 grand a year or this
non-profit or something else versus going and getting paid a million dollars a
year at one of these big companies, it's really impossible, right? I mean,
I don't know your situation, but when I graduated,
that was the biggest sort of Damocles over my neck was the student debt that I
had. And so, but when they go there, what products are they working on?
This is unfettered free agent ism.
Imagine that you had a professional sports league where there was no salary cap.
What would you do?
You would go and hire and you would sign every single great player at stick them
on the bench. You be guaranteed to win a championship.
You'd be a monopolistic championship winner year in, year out.
You're saying that they get paid to do nothing because when you say the beds,
that's what I thought of. Yeah.
No, no, no. That's, that's, that's, that is,
that is the exact explicit strategy. Absolutely. So,
so this is why I think again, we have to find market-driven solutions.
We have to find a way to use technology to build successful for profit
companies, because we have to convince all these people that are frankly,
withering and dying on the vine at these companies that they should be working
at these young dynamic businesses. You know, this is the forward bleeding edge.
Like if you think about what happened in 1969, right?
The Apollo project was the pinnacle of innovation in America,
but what did you really have in that moment?
But you had was an extremely diverse ecosystem where you had a public private
partnership.
You had the government that was basically an enormous balance sheet,
plus a lot of regulatory freedom and the ability to explore,
which then saw the germination of hundreds of companies and an ecosystem,
trying to get America into space and men to the moon.
And then back now we have the exact opposite.
We have the federal government that isn't exactly sure what its posture should
be. They work with an incredibly dated set of laws from antitrust to otherwise
section two 30 and otherwise.
And then we have a handful of companies that are effectively monopolies that
understand that their balance sheet is a tool that their balance sheet is
equivalent to most other governments in the world,
except maybe the United States. Right? If you,
if you put the GDP of countries on a list and then put the market cap of these
big companies together,
these five companies are probably top 50 countries. Sure. Right.
And so, and so, yeah, you can greenmail people.
You can basically work on all kinds of nonsense, nonsense, and random stuff.
And as a result, innovation slows down, um,
progress slows down as a result,
wage growth slows down as a result people's frustrations grow.
And then they point to capitalism except really, again, what it is,
is a bunch of financialization on one side and green mail and hostage taking on
the other,
that it basically trapped a whole cohort of young people in working on the
things that really matter.
I spent a number of years trying to counteract this.
I don't know how much you know about my work with venture for America. So what,
what, uh, we did was we recruited enterprising, young people,
some of them technical,
some of them not to work at early stage growth companies in Detroit,
new Orleans, Baltimore, Cleveland, um, Birmingham,
uh, and another half dozen cities around the country that are not New York,
San Francisco, um, with the thought process being exactly what you described,
which is look right now, if you're a whiz kid out of a lot of places, um,
banks and consulting firms and tech companies will wave money at you.
And then you will go there and you will do something that's not super, uh,
socially productive. And so wouldn't,
you rather start a business in a place or help a business grow in a place that,
uh, could use the talent, could use the energy. You could use the help I spent,
uh,
six and a half years running a nonprofit that did this and has done this for,
at this point. Um, hundreds, maybe thousands of young people.
And I saw the market forces. You were describing in action,
where if you're a really bright kid out of Penn and
you go to a,
up in new Orleans and then you see your friends getting paid six figures.
If it's a bank, maybe more, if it's, you know, certain,
certain tech firms and you look up, you're like, Oh my gosh, like,
what's going on? Am I missing out? Cause I'm here in new Orleans working for,
you know, a certain amount of money. It's a very difficult landscape. Um,
you know, venture for America had a degree of, uh,
of success. But also I realized the enormity of the problem.
There was a tweet during the middle of the pandemic where some guy was like, um,
he was an employee at Google and then had pretended to quit and got a job
at Facebook and then was being paid by both.
And because they're working from home, nobody knows
it's like out of Silicon Valley or office space.
And you think this is an absolute joke. And meanwhile, you know,
the earth is burning to the ground, you know, you know, we can't,
we can't even figure out how to like, uh,
do anything except distribute burritos by cars, to people. I mean,
it's kind of crazy.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notification so we can let you know every time we have a new
episode.